und damit können wir schon auf den
nächsten Tagesordnungspunkt schauen da
geht es um das
inflationsausgleichsgesetz und wie der
Name schon sagt möchte die
Bundesregierung und die
Koalitionsfraktionen wollen mit diesem
Gesetz die Menschen entlasten denn
natürlich durch die Inflation sind viele
Familien viele Personen noch mal stärker
belastet müssen auch mit den hohen
gas-strompreisen klarkommen und die
Regierung will zum Beispiel auch die
kalte Progression die natürlich
bekämpfen deswegen soll es zum Beispiel
einen höheren
Grundfreibetrag geben
und auch die Einkommensteuer soll
gesenkt werden denn wenn wir mal auf die
kalte Progression schauen dass die wird
ja oft auch als schleichende
Steuererhöhung
benannt und
jetzt komme ich schon zum ersten Redner
Christoph Meier stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender der FDP eröffnet
hier die Debatte vollständige Abbau der
kalten Progression kommt keine
heimlichen Steuererhöhung die entlasten
48 Millionen Bürgerinnen und Bürger das
Versprechen halten wir und dass seine
gute Nachricht für alle deutschen oder
alle Bürgerinnen und Bürger
wir haben in den parlamentarischen
Beratungen ein sehr guten Gesetzentwurf
von Finanzministerin Christian Linder
noch besser gemacht wir Lasten
zusätzlich um 14,6 Milliarden Euro und
das ganze bei Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse wir haben zusätzlich in
dem Gesetzentwurf verbessert
Anpassung bei der Einkommenssteuer so
dass wieder seit 90% der
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler
keinen Soli entrichten müssen dass sein
klares Zeichen dass wir die Mitte und
die Leistungsträger entlasten dass wir
Lohnsteigerungen nicht wegsteuern
sondern bei den Bürgern und Bürgern
belassen wollen und wir vereinheitlichen
das Kindergeld auf 250 Euro für jedes
Kind das ist die größte Erhöhung die es
in der Bundesrepublik je gegeben hat
kann man klatschen
wir unterstützen Familien gerade im
Bereich von geringeren und mittleren
Einkommen damit überproportional wir
machen das Kindergeld unbürokratischer
und auch das haben wir in den letzten
Tagen in diesen Gesetzentwurf noch
hinbekommen da bin ich besonders dankbar
für meine Damen und Herren und der
vollständige Ausgleich der Inflation es
ist eine Frage der Gerechtigkeit wir
haben das immer gesagt und es seit
Jahren praktizierte Praxis dass wir hier
zu einer Korrektur in unserem
Steuersystem kommen und das dient am
Ende des Tages den Bürgern es ist eine
direkte strukturelle Entlastung und wer
das nicht mittragen möchte und das sage
ich auch vor der Debatte die in den
letzten zwei Tagen sich wieder so ein
bisschen entwickelt hat den möchte ich
daran erinnern dass die starken
Schultern nach unserem Steuerrecht schon
jetzt überproportional mehr tragen und
ihren Anteil zur Finanzierung unseres
Gemeinwesens leisten
und deswegen muss es auch in der Krise
gelten dass das Geld an die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger zurückgegeben wird wer neue
Abgaben höhere Steuern mehr Bürokratie
fordert verkennt die Realität in
Deutschland wir müssen
feststellen dass Bürger und Unternehmen
in diesem Land immer mehr bezahlen
müssen immer mehr Bürokratie vor sich
haben das verhindert
Leistungsbereitschaft das schadet am
Ende des Tages den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland und gerade in der Krise in
der wir jetzt sind
ich erinnere an die Debatte noch vor ein
paar Jahren grenzendes Wachstums und wie
wir uns als Gesellschaft davon befreien
können wir sehen doch gerade jetzt in
Angesicht der Rezession die vor uns
steht dass wir nicht über Grenzen des
Wachstums sprechen müssen und über
mehrwachstum sprechen müssen darüber
sprechen müssen wir Wachstum erzeugen
können und wir Deutschland stärken
erhalten können meine Damen und Herren
und dazu gehört es auch zentral dass wir
individuelle Leistungsbereitschaft und
Innovation fördern und belohnen und das
tun wir mit diesem
inflationsausgleichsgesetzes allerdings
nur ein kleiner Punkt eigentlich
brauchen wir eine Zeitenwende in der
Steuer- und Haushaltspolitik mehr
strukturelle Entlastungen ein
Unternehmenssteuerreform eine
Weiterentwicklung des beschlossenen
belastungsmoratoriums und wir müssen die
Staatsaufgaben konsolidieren nicht
einfach immer mehr wie in den letzten
zehn Jahren sondern wir müssen Ausgaben
priorisieren dann schaffen wir es die
Schuldenbremse einzuhalten und wir
schaffen auf der anderen Seite auch
effizient mit den Mitteln der
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern umzugehen
die Ampelkoalition macht mit dem
Inflationsausgleich den einzig richtigen
Schritt Christian Linder und die Ampel
folgen damit den Vorgängerregierungen
und ich prognostiziere dass wir auch in
zwei Jahren erneut Wort halten werden
gemeinsam mit dem Kanzler mit dem
Finanzminister und mit der gesamten
Ampelkoalition werden wir auch dann
wieder heimliche Steuererhöhungen
verhindern ich danke für die
Aufmerksamkeit und freue mich dass wir
dieses Gesetz nun endlich auf den Weg
bringen danke
Christoph Meyer hat hier die Debatte
eröffnet die Unionsfraktion hat hier
übrigens zu dem Gesetzentwurf einen
Entschließungsantrag
eingereicht und für die Union sprechen
wird jetzt ihr stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender Matthias
Mittelberg
geschätzte frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen wir werden
diesem Gesetzesvorhaben heute zustimmen
dass Inflationsausgleich
ausgleichsgesetz ist die richtige
Maßnahme und auch die angemessene
Maßnahme wir haben diese Praxis ja
gemeinsam mit der FDP eingeführt 2012
und wir beglückwünschen auch die FDP
dass sie sich in dieser Koalition jetzt
durchgesetzt hat mit dieser Maßnahme
ausdrücklich es geht hier schlicht und
das muss man sagen um eine
Selbstverständlichkeit denn ausgeglichen
wird eine Steuererhöhung die sich
einfach faktisch aus der
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung ergibt die
wir aber hier in diesem Hause nie
besprochen und beschlossen haben die
also eigentlich auch keine
Rechtfertigung hat wir geben den Bürgern
eigentlich nur das Geld zurück was sie
über eine schleichende Steuererhöhung
zusätzlich an den Staat entrichten
mussten sie sind sowieso schon als
Bürger mit der hohen Inflation
hinreichend gepeinigt sie haben ungefähr
acht neun zehn Prozent Wertverlust ihrer
Kaufkraft ihres Einkommens in diesem
Jahr die fallen weg also ihr Einkommen
ist entsprechend weniger wert sie
kriegen dann vielleicht eine
Lohnerhöhung von drei vier Prozent da
freuen sie sich dann erst drüber dann
machen sie die Erfahrung dass ihnen der
größte Teil davon weggesteuert wird und
dieser Effekt wird noch stärker sein
wenn sie eben eine Lohnerhöhung kriegen
und sie dann in der Steuerprogression im
Tarif ansteigen weil sie an nominal mehr
verdienen und dann steigen sie schon
immer weiter in Richtung
Spitzensteuersatz und das ist genau der
progressionseffekt den wir jetzt
ausgleichen wir geben Ihnen also das
zurück was Sie was Ihnen durch die
Inflation durch die Preisentwicklung
sonst noch zusätzlich genommen wäre und
das ist nur billig und gerecht und das
ist das Mindeste was wir den Schulden
die in diesem Land hart arbeiten und den
ganzen Laden durch ihre Steuerzahlung
überhaupt erst am Laufen halten
so erfreulich ist auch dass die
Koalition die Tarife zuletzt auch noch
mal angepasst hat an den neuen
progressionsbericht das war zu Anfang ja
anders geplant nicht so erfreulich ist
und das verschweigen Sie hier natürlich
so ein bisschen dass sie die Progression
nicht ausgleichen für das laufende Jahr
das heißt in diesem Jahr zahlen die
Leute diese verdeckten schleichenden
Steuererhöhungen im nächsten Jahr erst
gleichen sie das aus und dass sie die
Schuldenbremse einhalten würden herr
Meier das diskutieren wir dann
vielleicht noch mal in zwei Wochen
werden wir die Haushaltsdebatte haben
wir haben eher den Eindruck dass sie
sehr einfallsreich und ihr Minister
leider sehr einfallsreich die
Schuldenbremse umgeht dazu fallen ihm
immer neue interessante Manöver ein aber
das werden wir dann in zwei Wochen
diskutieren
im übrigen warten wir hier immer noch
auf die wesentlichen Maßnahmen mit denen
sie die Bürger in diesem Land in dieser
Krisensituation entlasten wollen wir
warten immer noch auf die konkreten
Vorschläge zur gaspreisbremse zur
strompreisbremse und sie sind auch
ungenügend unterwegs was das Thema
Ausweitung des Angebots bei Gas und
Strom angeht auch da und da hätte es ja
die Möglichkeit für Entlastungen gegeben
was das Weiterlaufen der drei
Kernkraftwerke angeht es geht hier um
Entlastung Frau Beck es geht um
Entlastung wir diskutieren in dieser
Debatte und Entlastung und ich will es
ihnen sehr genau erklären die
Wirtschaftsweise Frau Grimm deren
gaspreismodell sie ja toll finden und
übernehmen die gleiche Wirtschaftsweise
hat ihnen ausgerechnet dass wenn Sie die
drei Kernkraftwerke weiter betreiben
würden im nächsten Jahr der Strompreis
für die Menschen in diesem Land bis zu
zwölf Prozent günstiger sein könnte das
wäre eine ganz gewaltige Entlastung für
die Bürger in diesem Land jeder würde
100 Prozent weniger für seinen Strom
zahlen müssen dass das nicht eintritt
das haben sie der Grünen Ideologie in
dieser ampelregierung der Uneinigkeit in
dieser ampelregierung zu verdanken und
so läuft es leider bei den Entlastungen
generell bei ihnen Entlastung für nicht
dann statt wenn es sinnvoll und
vernünftig für den Bürger ist das ist
jetzt einmal der Ausnahmefall hier
Entlastung finden bei Ihnen in der Regel
dann statt wenn es gut für die Stimmung
das Klima in ihrer permanent
zerstrittenen Ampel ist
Matthias Mittelberg kritisiert hier der
Einsatz der Maßnahmen wenn Bürgerinnen
und Bürger entlastet werden sollen es
ist ein Vorwurf auf denen Michael
schrodi jetzt reagieren könnte erst der
nächste Redner und auch
finanzpolitischer Sprecher der
Sozialdemokraten im Deutschen Bundestag
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren in Zeiten
großer Herausforderungen hat diese
Ampelkoalition schon zahlreiche
Entlastungsmaßnahmen auf den Weg
gebracht der Abwehrschirm mit 200
Milliarden Euro der eingesetzt wird
unter anderem um eine gaspreisbremse auf
den Weg zu bringen die strompreisbremse
da werden wir Energiekosten senken wir
werden die Inflation damit auch
bekämpfen wir haben ja Mittelberg
übrigens auch
entlastungspakete auf dem Weg gebracht
in einem Volumen von 190 Milliarden Euro
vielleicht sowas über nur einzeln
aufschreiben dass sie sich merken sie
stellen sie hin und sagen wir hätten
nichts getan wir tun das wir finanzieren
das auch während sie nur fordern ohne
eine Gegenfinanzierung überhaupt hier
mal vorzuschlagen das ist unseriös wir
machen unsere Arbeit
und wir machen das mit Direktzahlungen
bisher mit der energiepreispauschale wir
haben eine Heizkostenzuschuss
Mehrwertsteuersenkungen das machen wir
und gerade kleine mittlere Einkommen zu
entlasten um sozialen Zusammenhalt zu
stärken um Unternehmen zu helfen um
Arbeitsplätze zu erhalten und das ist
gut so das
inflationsausgleichsgesetz ist ein Teil
des dritten
entlastungs-
wir passen dann
entsprechend dann den Tarif im
Einkommensteuertarif an in Zeiten
solcher krisenhaften Herausforderungen
ist aber auch dieser was sind diese
Berichte
haben sie eine besondere Bedeutung
und es wird klar wenn wir uns anschauen
wie stark wir nun den Menschen auch
helfen die Menschen entlasten der
Grundfreibetrag stieg im Jahr 2022 Herr
Middelberg bereits um 600 und drei Euro
da haben wir schon etwas gemacht zum
Ausgleich der kalten Progression er
steigt noch einmal um 561 im nächsten
Jahr um 696 im
1860 Euro insgesamt auf
11.604 Euro wird dieser Grundfreibetrag
angehoben ab dem überhaupt Steuern
anfallen das ist eine wahrlich große
Entlastung für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren Kinderfreibetrag steigt um 924
Euro auf 9.312 auch der Betrag für den
steuerlichen Abzug und
Unterhaltsleistungen steigt die Vorgaben
werden da getroffen durch den
Existenzminimumbericht
dieses Existenzminimum steuerlich auch
freizustellen reist über das müsst ihr
ja tun wir machen aber auch einiges und
zwar mit großem finanziellen Aufwand was
über das hinausgeht was den
verfassungsrechtlich tun müssten die
kalte Progression ist angesprochen oder
würde übrigens Herr Mittelberg von ihrer
Fraktion in freigestellt dass wir das
tun würden und jetzt haben sie auch
wieder gesagt die FDP hätte uns
rüberziehen müssen dass wir das tun nein
nein es andersrum wir haben mit den
Experten über den Effekt der kalten
Progression nochmal gesprochen
inflationsbedingte lohnt zu wechseln
führen zu einem höheren Steuertarif und
diesen Effekt gleichen wir aus das haben
wir mit Ihnen zusammen in der großen
Koalition gemacht das machen wir jetzt
auch aber diesen besonderen Zeiten gehen
wir sogar darüber hinaus was mit ihnen
nicht was wir mit ihnen nicht gemacht
haben wir nehmen nämlich den kompletten
Inflation 7, zwei Prozent werden die
Eckwerte nach rechts verschoben im
nächsten Jahr über die Sommer 6,3
Prozent das sind riesige Entlastungen
für die Steuerzahlerinnen und
Steuerzahler die wir auf den Weg bringen
über das hinaus was sie mit ihnen
gemacht haben von der cdu/cs und ein
letztes in den Entlastungsmaßnahmen ist
die Kindergelderhöhung wir haben
normalerweise eine Gleichlauf in der
Erhöhung von Kinderfreibetrag und
Kindergeld wir haben intensiv darüber
beraten wir Familien die auch stark
getroffen sind von den Preissteigerungen
entlasten können
und wir haben nun die größte
Kindergelderhöhung in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland in dieser
Krisenzeit auf den Weg gebracht es ein
deutliches Zeichen wir werden den
Familien auch in dieser Krise helfen und
sie nicht alleine lassen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren von
219 Euro steigt
das Kind 350 Euro plus 31 Euro ab dem
ersten
2023 und ist auch in erster Schritt hin
Richtung zu einer Kindergrundsicherung
die immer noch wir auf dem Schirm haben
damit wir Kinder aus der Armut holen vor
zwei Jahren meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren von der cdu/csu waren das
Entlastungsvolumen 11,8 Milliarden Euro
jetzt hatten wir 18,5 angesetzt wir
haben noch mal 14,5 Milliarden
draufgesetzt das Entlastungsvolumen
liegt jetzt bei 33 Milliarden Euro mehr
über das hinaus was ihr müssten wir
sorgen für sozialen Zusammenhalt wir
stärken Familien wir entlassen die
ArbeitnehmerInnen Arbeitnehmer die
Menschen können sich auf die
Ampelkoalition verlassen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
ein letztes noch
weil es auch von ihm kam oft kam die
Erzählung der Staat sei Profiteur der
Inflation
den Mehreinnahmen die wir haben stehen
deutlich höhere mehr Ausgaben gegenüber
die 33 Milliarden sind nur ein Teil 190
Milliarden allein für die
entlastungspakete und es ist auch
richtig so weil nichts zu tun wäre keine
Alternative das würde zu
Arbeitsplatzverlust führen sozusagen
Verwerfungen im Grunde ist das also
richtig so aber und ich glaube das ist
echt was was wir aus dem Jahresgutachten
der Wirtschaftsweisen schon herausnehmen
müssen wir brauchen eine soziale Balance
tun uns aber auf Kosten ihrer Kollegen
wir tun das
und werden das tun mit einer sozialen
Balance starke Schultern müssen ihren
Anteil auch daran haben noch mehr als
bisher insofern ist ein gutes Gesetz die
Union wird hoffentlich dann auch
zustimmen und ich freue mich darüber
dass wir ein so groß Entlastungsvolumen
für die Menschen auf den Weg bringen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich mache
darauf aufmerksam dass natürlich jeder
entsprechend der Anteile der Redezeit
hier zu Wort kommen soll dass Sie aber
darauf achte dass die verabredete
Redezeit insgesamt eingehalten wird wir
kommen im Moment zu beiden Sitzungsende
vier Uhr morgen früh an wir müssen alles
ausführlich diskutieren aber im Rahmen
der verabredeten regeln
so wir machen weiter das Wort hat der
Abgeordnete Kai Gottschalk für die
afd-fraktion
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin vor
allen Dingen aber auch verirrte
Steuerzahler
das was wir hier heute diskutieren und
Herr schrodi das war wieder
Etikettenschwindel der besonderen
ac-entlasten nicht sie erhalten nur die
Kaufkraft da werde ich gleich im
Einzelnen zu eingehen aber das war eine
Falschbehauptung dass sie entlasten
würden also ich möchte aber zunächst mal
auf die cdu/csu zugehen und sagen mein
Gott herzlichen Glückwunsch sie kommen
so langsam in der Opposition an und
nähern sich sogar Forderungen der AFD an
ich war ja fast platt und habe mich auf
dem Hosenboden gesetzt eine jährliche
Überprüfung der kalten Progression etwas
was meine Fraktion und ich hier seit
Jahren fordern da bewegen sich auf uns
zu deswegen nur die Enthaltung jetzt
wäre es aber nur noch ein sehr kleiner
Schritt für Sie meine Damen und Herren
von der CDU aber ein unheimlich großer
Schritt für die Menschen da draußen wenn
sie tatsächlich endlich zum geplanten
Automatismus sie haben heute wieder die
Möglichkeit gleich dem zuzustimmen
nämlich dem Tarif Rädern damit wir
wegkommen dass wir alle zwei Jahre meine
Damen und Herren auf dem
progressionsbericht Warten der dann aber
noch nicht mal angemessen umgesetzt wird
und die Bürgerinnen und Bürger werden
mitnichten entlastet das ist eine
Teilentlastung und deswegen werden wir
diesem Gesetz nur mit Enthaltung
entsprechend entgegentreten meine Damen
und Herren aber
zum einzelnen
ich sage so wie es ist wenn man es
definiert der Name
inflationsausgleichsgesetz an sich ist
schon eine Lüge denn in diesem Gesetz
gibt es für das Jahr 2020 22 überhaupt
keine weiteren Entlastung sie haben eben
die Erhöhung des Grundfreibetrages
angesprochen ich habe es mal
ausgerechnet sie haben also rückwirkend
die Menschen um 6,2 Prozent beim
Existenzminimum die Menschen die jeden
Tag zur Arbeit gehen entlastet bei einer
pro einer Inflation jetzt im Oktober von
10,4 und wahrscheinlich einer
durchschnittsinflation in diesem Jahr
von über acht Prozent wo ist das eine
Entlastung das ist eine Verhörung der
Leute die arbeiten meine Damen und
Herren folgen Sie unserem Antrag 12.600
Euro die sind angemessen
und schauen wir mal wie die badbank die
hier ja sitzt oder auch
schuldenkoalition mit diesem Problem
dann weiter umgeht auf Grundlage des
fünften steuerprogressionsbericht sie
haben den ja angesprochen rechnet die
Bundesregierung mit 7,2 Prozent für das
Jahr 22 immerhin und jetzt kommt mit
6,3% für das Jahr 23 und genau um diese
7,2% von denen ich eben sprach diese
jetzt vornehmen wollen die gelten dann
mal ab dem nächsten Jahr meine Damen und
Herren die Probleme liegen jetzt schon
seit einem Jahr vor aber sie gehen die
nicht an und meine Damen und Herren
liebe Steuerzahler wenn sie jetzt schon
sauer sind und das berechtigt dass die
von der Bundesregierung versprochene
inflationsausgleichsmechanismen ist die
hier nicht greifen komme ich mal zu den
tatsächlichen Zahlen immerhin es gibt
noch ein paar Fachleute im
Wirtschaftsministerium die haben nämlich
bei Klimaschutz und Wirtschaft geschätzt
dass im nächsten Jahr wir eine Inflation
im Durchschnitt von
Prozent haben denn es gibt sogar
renommierte Institute die gehen von 8,8
Prozent aus wissen Sie was da ihre 7,2
sind die nächste Verhüllung der Menschen
die da oben sitzen und fleißig zur
Arbeit fahren und dann auch von ihren
klimadogieren daran gehindert werden
Ihre Aufträge umzusetzen
wo diese Regierung also von Entlastungen
in Form eines inflationsausgleichs
spricht bleibt im Dunkeln aber um dem
Ganzen die Krone aufzusetzen meine Damen
und Herren möchte ich zum Abschluss noch
erwähnen das ist zu einer wirklichen
Abschaffung der kalten Progression auf
Freibeträge auf Pauschbeträge und
Höchstbeträge nehmen wir mal die
berühmte Pendlerpauschale oder
Entfernungspauschale gar nicht kommt
eine besondere Stilblüte ist die
Werbungskostenpauschale die ist nämlich
meine Damen und Herren seit 1955 so hat
man sie lieb als Steuerzahler nicht
geändert worden nach Berechnung des BUND
der Steuerzahlers müsste diese jetzt
inflationsbereinigt bei 573 Euro liegen
wissen Sie wo die liegt zurzeit bei 102
Euro und genau dieser rote Faden zieht
sich durch die Politik dieser Regierung
meine Damen und Herren auch hierfür
werden wir übrigens als AFD und als
echte service-opposition ein Antrag
Vorbringen da können sie dann ihre
Ehrlichkeit und ihre Fürsorge für die
Arbeitnehmer zeigen indem wir eine
automatische Anpassung wie in der
Schweiz ich sage bewusst ähnlich
vornehmen werden damit die Menschen
automatisch entlastet werden und nicht
nach ihrem politischen Kalkül und
gutünden meine Damen und Herren vielen
Dank
wenn die Löhne und das Einkommen steigen
aber nur so viel dass sie gerade die
Inflation ausgleichen dann steigt ja die
Steuerlast man rutscht in einen höheren
Steuersatz und das bedeutet man hat
trotz höheren Gehalts nicht mehr Geld in
der Tasche das ist die sogenannte kalte
Progression und Bundesfinanzminister
Christian Lindner hat immer wieder
betont dass er gegen diese angehen
möchte auch das soll mit diesem
inflationsausgleichsgesetz Geschehen und
wurde ja auch hier schon häufiger
angesprochen Sascha Müller spricht jetzt
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Kindergelderhöhung
gegenüber
gegenüber diesem Jahr steigt das
Kindergeld für das erste und zweite Kind
um jeweils 31 Euro und für das dritte
Kind um 25 Euro sodass wir am Ende bei
einheitlich 250 Euro Kindergeld für alle
Kinder landen egal ob das erste zweite
dritte vierte oder weiteres Kind das ist
wunderbar und eine wichtige
Unterstützung für Familien denn
insbesondere Familien haben mit der
hohen Inflation zu kämpfen und das
Gesetz dann mit dem Namen
inflationsausgleichsgesetz trägt diesen
Namen absolut zurecht
vor allem aber und auch das ist
wunderbar sind wir so bereits einen
wichtigen Schritt auf den Weg hin zur
Kindergrundsicherung gegangen und an
dieser Stelle
darf natürlich nicht vergessen werden
dass Kinder im Bürgergeld oder auch
Kinder von Alleinerziehenden nicht in
dem Umfang profitieren denn hier wird
das Kindergeld beim Bürgergeld oder an
Unterhalt angerechnet mit dem Bürgergeld
erreichen wir aber für die erste Gruppe
höhere Sätze und für die andere Gruppe
wollen wir schon bald eine
Steuergutschrift eben für
Alleinerziehende einführen damit auch
diese Kinder profitieren können
natürlich gibt es in dem Gesetz auch
Dinge die wir im Sinne eines
Gesamtpaketes mittragen auch wenn Sie
nicht unsere Idee oder unsere
Herzensanliegen sind es ist richtig dass
der Kinderfreibetrag im Zuge der
Existenzminimums angepasst werden muss
und deshalb selbstverständlich auch
angepasst wird dennoch bleibt der Effekt
erhalten dass damit die Kinder von
Eltern mit hohen Einkommen somit mehr
erhalten als die Kinder von nicht so von
Eltern von nicht so hohen Einkommen das
werden wir auf dem weiteren Weg zur
Kindergrundsicherung noch einmal genauer
betrachten bleibt
bleibt die Anpassung der Eckwerte zum
Ausgleich der kalten Progression dazu
ist medial sehr viel gesagt und auch
kontrovers diskutiert worden und dass
das dieses Mal so besonders kontrovers
diskutiert wurde liegt natürlich an der
besonderen Situation in der wir uns
befinden es gibt die Lesart bei dem
Thema das ohne die Anpassung der
Eckwerte es real zu einer höheren
Steuerbelastung kommt und es gibt die
Lesart dass die Rechtsverschiebung
starke Schultern absolut mehr entlastet
als schwache Schultern beide Lesarten
sind in sich schlüssig aber es ist kein
Geheimnis dass wir stark der zweiten
Lesart zuneigen wir gehen bei diesem
Gesetz hier mit der Rat den uns die
wirtschaftsweißen hinsichtlich starker
Schultern eben der Bundesregierung
mitgegeben haben sollte aber unserer
Meinung nach verkünftige Entscheidungen
berücksichtigt werden ich danke für die
Aufmerksamkeit
soweit der Obmann der Grünen empfehlen
ganz Ausschuss Sascha Müller und auf
jeden Fall nun Christian Görke der
Sprecher für Finanzpolitik der
Linksfraktion hier im Deutschen
Bundestag
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen was hier heute
vorliegt ist der wahr gewordene
steuersenkungstraum eines FDP-Chefs der
die Zeichen der Zeit nicht erkannt hat
und das attestiert der
Bundesfinanzminister Ihnen ja auch der
eigene Expertenrat der Bundesregierung
die Wirtschaftsweise und mit Erlaubnis
der Präsidentin würde ich gern aus
diesem Gutachten zitieren der Zeitpunkt
für den Abbau der kalten Progression ist
ungünstig gewählt und was sie Herr
Müller unter einem
inflationsausgleichsgesetz hier
benennen ist in Wahrheit ein
spitzenverdienerentlastungsgesetz so
weit so gut meine Damen und Herren
gerade von SPD
und der Grünen dass sie diese Mission
dass sie diese Mission hier so mitmachen
da ist mir wirklich manchmal die Spucke
weggeblieben denn durch die Verschiebung
der tarifwerte werden die
Spitzenverdiener am meisten begünstigt
und daher Zahlen nicht lügen mal die
Belege bei ihrem Spitzenverdiener
entlastungsgesetz spart ein sehr gut
verdienender Single
1338 Euro pro Jahr der
Durchschnittsverdiener 500 und 2 der
Geringverdiener 361 und wer dann noch in
Teilzeit malocht der und kaum
Einkommensteuer zahlt der leer aus das
schlägt doch meine Damen und Herren
wirklich den politischen Fass hier den
Boden aus um das nochmal klarzustellen
wir sind als Linke selbstverständlich
grundsätzlich dafür dass die kalte
Progression dass die kalte Progression
ausgeglichen würde aber in der
momentanen Situation
bitte vor allen Dingen bei denen die
unter dieser Krise zu kämpfen haben und
eigentlich den Karren hier am Lauf
halten das sind die Kassiererinnen und
Kassierer die Postboten die
Grundschullehrer die Polizisten und
nicht in der dax-manager der
Bundesligaprofi oder die
Unternehmensberaterin meine Damen und
Herren und übrigens
dass wir nicht nur so verstehe Ihre
aufregend als FDP das sind ihre
Wirtschaftsweisen die in das empfehlen
und deshalb sagen die sogar sie wollen
den Spitzensteuersatz zeitweise erhöhen
oder sogar der Vorschlag eines
energie-soli für Besserverdienende und
übrigens meine Damen und Herren das
Gesetz ist übrigens noch schweineteuer
man fragt sie wie das sein kann wo doch
der Finanzminister überall kürzt oder
sparen will um dann die Schuldenbremse
wenigstens ideologiefrei einzuhalten
keine höhere energiepasspauschale eben
mehrwertsteuersenk auf
Grundnahrungsmittel kamen nicht 9 €
Ticket all diese vorschlagen auf dem
Tisch abgelehnt und jetzt 50 Milliarden
kostet jetzt das ganze mehr als die
Hälfte fließt in die dicken Geldbeutel
und mehr als die Hälfte kommt nicht aus
dem Bundeshaushalt sondern aus den
Ländern und den Kommunen in dieser
Bundesrepublik und ich habe sie schon
mal gesagt Herr Bundesfinanzminister sie
schmücken sich ja mit diesem Gesetz mit
diesem Spitzenverdienern lassen Gesetz
sie haben fettes hingestellt haben die
Vorspeise bezahlt aber haben
unabgesprochen die Rechnung beim Nachbar
auf den Tisch gelegt und meine Damen und
Herren zur Wahrheit gehört gestern um
11:48 Uhr gab es dann den Gesetzentwurf
da hat man den Länder und Kommunen noch
mal 3,5 Milliarden Euro ins Obligo
geschrieben das ist unanständig
Finanzpolitik und insofern lehnen wir in
Gesetzentwurf ab
das Wort hat die Kollegin Frauke
Heiligenstadt für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren sehr geehrter
Herr Görke ich habe ein ganz anderen
Namen für das Gesetz was wir jetzt
gleich beschließen werden denn dieses
Gesetz
inflationsausgleichsgesetzes eigentlich
nicht vollständig sondern das ist das
Gesetz zur Unterstützung von
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmern und
Familien in diesem Land das ist mein
Name dafür und ich führe auch gerne aus
warum das der Fall ist wir haben uns
zweifelhaft eine sehr hohe Inflation und
da müssen wir natürlich auch mit der
Besteuerung von Einkommen darauf
reagieren
infolge der Inflation das habe ich
bereits in der ersten Debatte zu diesem
Gesetz hier im Hohen Haus gesagt steigen
die Kosten für viele nicht nur die
Energiekosten die Heizkosten die
Mobilitätskosten und auch Lebensmittel
sind deutlich teurer geworden das
bedeutet für viele Menschen in unserem
Land eine immense Mehrbelastung weil das
verfügbare bekommen in den Familien eben
nicht im gleichen Maße gestiegen ist
Lohnerhöhung haben nur zum Teil dazu
beitragen können diese Schere
tatsächlich zu schließen und hinzu kommt
dass man bei der ein oder anderen
Lohnerhöhung dann tatsächlich in eine
andere Steuerprogression kommt und dann
noch weniger Netto vom Brutto hat als
man vielleicht vorher hatte diese
sogenannte kalte Progression soll unter
anderem mit dem vorliegenden Gesetz
vermieden werden aus diesem Grunde
verschieben wir auch die entsprechenden
steuererklärte bei der Einkommensteuer
grundlage hierfür ist unter anderem der
dem Parlament vorliegende
progressionsbericht und es ist auch
richtig dass wir das immer auch hier
parlamentarisch diskutieren und kein
Automatismus dafür einbauen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
mit der Anpassung dieser heckwerte und
der deutlichen Erhöhung des
steuerfreibetrages im übrigen der
höchsten Erhöhung des steuerfreibetrages
dies je gegeben hat unterstützen wir die
Menschen die Einkommensteuer zahlen und
das sind nicht ausschließlich
Spitzenverdiener sondern das sind auch
mittlere und kleinere Einkommen das
heißt wir unterstützen natürlich auch
die Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
in diesem Land wir lassen
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer in
diesem Land nicht allein neben diesen
Entlastung haben wir nämlich zum
Beispiel bereits in den vergangenen
Wochen weitere Entlastungen für
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer auf
den Weg gebracht die Erhöhung der
fernpenderpauschale die
energiepreispauschale die Erhöhung des
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrages wir werden
zudem mit den Ländern gemeinsam die
Einführung des deutschlandtickets an den
Start bringen mit den öffentlichen
Verkehrsmitteln ist es dann günstiger
zur Arbeit zu fahren weitere
Entlastungen sind geplant unter anderem
mit dem Jahres Gesetz zur Erhöhung der
homeoffice-pauschale meine Damen und
Herren die hart arbeitenden Menschen in
unserem Land egal ob Sie ein kleines
Einkommen haben oder ein großes
Einkommen haben werden deutlich weniger
Steuern zahlen und das ist auch eine
gute Antwort für die die entsprechend
unseren Staat finanzieren und tragen
das
dies auch insbesondere für niedrige
Einkommen bereits greift erkennt man
schon daran dass wir den Grundfreibetrag
für die Einkommensteuer deutlich erhöhen
und auch an die Werte aus dem
existenzminimumsbericht Anpassen im
übrigen ist die Erhöhung oder die
Einführung des Bürgergeldes auch ein
guter Grund hier die Anpassung
entsprechend vorzunehmen das ergibt sich
nämlich auch aus diesem
existenzminimumsbericht möglicherweise
müssen Sie sogar gar keine Steuern mehr
bezahlen wenn Sie dann direkt unter
diesen Freibetrag fallen das Wichtigste
aber ist dass wir zusätzlich den
Familien eine Unterstützung gewähren
indem wir das Kindergeld ist es bereits
ausgeführt worden auf 250 Euro für jedes
Kind pro Monat erhöhen und das ist nicht
nur eine deutliche Steigerung gegenüber
dem Gesetzentwurf der ja schon eine
Erhöhung vorgesehen hat sondern das ist
insgesamt die deutlichste Erhöhung von
Kindergeld die es in diesem Land je
gegeben hat und damit
das nicht nur so allgemein als Aussage
steht vielleicht auch noch mal ganz
konkret bei drei Kindern hat man bisher
7.956 Euro im Jahr Kindergeld bekommen
jetzt werden es 9.000 Euro bei
zweitkindern
5.256 Euro jetzt werden es 6000 Euro und
selbst bei einem Kind werden es von
2.628 Euro auf 3000 Euro eine deutlich
Erhöhung sein ich finde das Gesetz dass
wir jetzt beschließen mit dem hier
zugrunde liegenden Gesetzentwurf das
wird in jedem Fall dazu beitragen dass
man es mit Recht Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer und Familien
unterstützungsgesetz nennen darf vielen
Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
Frauke Heiligenstadt war das und sie ist
Mitglied im Finanzausschuss wie auch der
nächste Redner Johannes Steininger für
die Unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kollegen
Kolleginnen ich möchte starten mit einem
ehrlichen Glückwunsch an den
Finanzminister sie haben sich
durchgesetzt in dieser Koalition das war
ehrlich gesagt in den letzten Monaten
auch was man so aus der Koalition selbst
gehört hat nicht selbstverständlich und
deswegen herzlichen Glückwunsch dass sie
sich durchgesetzt haben dass die kalte
Progression jetzt für 23 und 24
ausgeglichen wird und man sieht aber
gleichzeitig auch man sieht gleichzeitig
auch das Opposition wirkt weil wir haben
uns hier auch in den letzten Monaten zu
diesem Gesetz eingebracht ich habe schon
vor einem Jahr hier an diesem Rednerpult
darauf hingewiesen dass sie das Thema
kalte Progression gar nicht im
Koalitionsvertrag drin stehen haben und
wir hatten die große Sorge das grüne und
SPD da nicht mitziehen werden und diese
Sorge hatte sich ja dann jetzt nicht
bestätigt aber es gab viel Grund dazu in
den letzten Wochen und Monaten und es
ist gut dass diese kalte Progression
jetzt ausgeglichen wird weil die kalte
Progression ist am Schluss ungerecht sie
ist unsozial und sie ist ehrlich gesagt
auch undemokratisch weil wir haben ja
heimliche Steuererhöhung die nicht durch
Parlament abgedeckt sind und deswegen
ist es richtig dass wir als cdu/csu das
mal vor Jahren eingeführt haben und dass
sie uns jetzt hier auch in der Folge das
ganze nachmachen
jetzt ist es natürlich jetzt ist es
natürlich so
ich habe hier so Einigkeit gehört aber
Einigkeit ist es eben nicht also Otto
von Bismarck soll ja mal gesagt haben
Gesetze sind wie Würste man sollte nicht
dabei sein wenn sie gemacht werden bei
diesem Gesetz war das so also Nummer für
die Öffentlichkeit diese Ampel war sich
bis Dienstag Nacht offensichtlich nicht
einig die Änderungsanträge wo es noch
mal zu diesen massiven Verbesserungen
gekommen sind sind erst am Ende des
Finanzausschuss gestern zu uns gekommen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren so
geht man nicht mit dem Parlament um so
geht man ehrlich gesagt auch nicht mit
der Opposition in einem
Gesetzgebungsverfahren um
und in den und ich habe mich und ich
habe mich ich habe mich geärgert in auch
am Wochenende als insbesondere von der
SPD Fake News Abteilung wieder mal
gesagt worden ist wir als Opposition wir
würden gegen alles stimmen was von der
Ampel kommt da hat man ja einiges gehört
ja aber das ist hier ein Beispiel wo es
eben gerade nicht so ist wir könnten uns
jetzt hier einfach machen wir könnten
sagen es ist nicht genug sie haben es
2022 jetzt nicht ausgeglichenes
Kindergeld ab dem vierten Kind ist über
unterproportional aber wir übernehmen in
diesem Parlament dann auch Verantwortung
wenn sie ordentliche Gesetze vorlegen
wenn sie im Verfahren auch auf uns hören
uns einbeziehen unsere Vorschläge dann
auch mit in die Änderungsanträge
einnehmen und deswegen machen wir als
cdu/csu hier ordentliche Politik eine
verantwortliche Politik und deswegen
werden wir diesen Gesetz auch zustimmen
und jetzt ist es ganz schade dass ich
nur noch 20 Sekunden habe um diese
ganzen
mathematischen Fehler der Redner von SPD
und Grünen hier ein bisschen aufzuräumen
vielleicht nur ein Satz natürlich ist
das ein historisch großes Volumen weil
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren wir
haben eine historisch hohe Inflation und
dann ist auch ganz klar wenn das
ausgeglichen wird dass dann das Volumen
auch sehr groß ist in diesem Sinne
werden den zustimmen also und ich
empfehle Ihnen in Zukunft hören Sie
öfters auf uns es tut dieser
Bundesrepublik gut
Johannes Steininger hat hier noch einmal
den Vorgang kritisiert wie dieser
Gesetzentwurf eingebracht wurde und das
wird hier wirklich im Schnellverfahren
ja wo das eingebracht und soll heute
gleich noch abgestimmt werden Katharina
Beck wird wahrscheinlich nur noch einmal
für diesen Gesetzentwurf werben für die
Zustimmung der Abgeordneten Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger es ist sehr
wichtig dieses
inflationsausgleichsgesetz in der
zweistelligen Milliardenhöhe einzuordnen
da rein in was für einer Zeit wir sind
es ist unfassbar große Krise und wir
gehen als Bundesregierung sehr beherzt
damit um und machen entlastungspakete
und abwehrschirme in über 300 Milliarden
Euro Höhe und die Situation ist
dramatisch wir haben zehn Prozent
Inflation
manche gaskundinnen müssen mit 95%
Inflationen rechnen und das kommt auf
eine Situation wo 40 Prozent der
Menschen in Deutschland keine Rücklagen
haben um diese Preissteigerungen
abzufedern in meiner Heimatstadt Hamburg
macht sich gerade jeder vierte Mensch
Gedanken darüber ob er überhaupt noch in
seiner Wohnung bleiben kann es ist also
wirklich dramatisch und ja wir haben
viel diskutiert über dieses Gesetz aber
es ist ein sehr gutes Gesetz denn wir
haben das eingeordnet in einen
Gesamtpaket was extrem gut ist wir
müssen die Ursachen bekämpfen wir bauen
die erneuerbaren Energien auf damit das
mittelfristig preisgünstige Energie in
Deutschland gibt damit wir unabhängig
werden von unserer Abhängigkeit von
Russland und anderen Staaten dann machen
wir auch die Energie günstiger für
Menschen und für Unternehmen wir machen
mit der Gas- und strompreisbremse
ermöglichen wir dass das erstmal wieder
bezahlbar wird und diese ganzen ad
hoc-entlastung ich glaube da sind wir
uns wirklich auch sehr einig in dieser
Ampel-Koalition das sind ad
hoc-belastungen aber wir können das
nicht immer so besser machen aber auch
da haben wir über 18 Maßnahmen gemacht
um die Menschen finanziell zu entlasten
da fange ich an beim 9 euro-ticket bis
49 euro-ticket für manche sind das über
die Hälfte Reduktion an Mobilitätskosten
die energiepreispauschalen wo auch
ärmere mehr profitieren als reichere den
Grundfreibetrag der gerade schon
gefeiert wurde und
jedes fünfte Kind in Deutschland lebt in
Kinderarmut und wir haben schon im
Sommer 100 Euro aufs Kindergeld drauf
gepackt wir haben für die
transfer-anzieherin 20 Euro im Monat
oben drauf getan auf den Kindern sofort
zu stark und es ist sehr großartig dass
wir mit diesem
inflationsausgleichsgesetzen und die
größte Kindergelderhöhung aller Zeiten
machen auf 250 Euro pro Kind
das ist ein absoluter Meilenstein auch
im Projekt unserer Familienministerin
von dieser Pause und der gesamten
ampelregierung die Kinder Grundsicherung
endlich auf den Weg zu bringen damit
dieses Schandmaul der Kinderarmut in
Deutschland endlich abgebaut wird
es ist kein Geheimnis
dass in diesem Gesetz regressiv
entlastet wird also viel verdienender
absolut betrachtet mehr profitieren aber
insgesamt gehen wir mit unseren
Entlastungen einen so unfassbar guten
Weg dass ich stolz bin Teil dieser
Regierung und dieser Fraktion der Ampel
zu sein vielen Dank
Katharina Beck von Bündnis 90 die Grünen
war das hat ja auch noch mal die
Familienministerin erwähnt Lisa pauset
sich ja auch besonders für eine
Kindergrundsicherung ein und damit
kommen wir zum letzten Redner vor der
Abstimmung Alois reiner CDU-Fraktion
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren der von der
Bundesregierung vorgelegte Gesetzentwurf
beinhaltet viele gute Punkte
insbesondere für Familien dazu zählen
die Anhebung des Kinderfreibetrages für
2022 bis 24 sowie die Anhebung der
höchst des Höchstbetrages für den
steuerlichen Abzugs von
Unterhaltsleistungen von 22 bis 24 und
bei der Anhebung des Kindergeldes auf
250 Euro pro Monat sind sie ja unserem
Vorschlag gefolgt man hätte noch darüber
hinausgehen können aber es ist schon
wirklich ganz gut man hätte die
kinderreichen Familien besser entlassen
können aber meine Damen und Herren die
Probleme der Menschen bestehen jetzt
jetzt im Jahr 2022 deshalb wäre es auch
notwendig gewesen den Ausgleich der
kalten Progression schon im 22 gelten
lassen sollen
wir sehen aber gerade auch in diesem
Gesetz dass die Zusammenarbeit zwischen
Regierung und
Opposition funktionieren kann wenn Sie
bereit sind auf den großen
Erfahrungsschatz von 16 Jahren Regierung
zurückzugreifen das hat nämlich hat man
jetzt gesehen es bringt was ich hätte
mir an dieser Stelle aber auch gewünscht
dass Sie an unseren dass Sie unseren
Entschließungsantrag in der Gänze
zugestimmt und diesen auch umgesetzt
hätten der Staat hat in diesem Jahr
bedingt durch die Inflation erheblich
mehr Steuern eingenommen und diese
sollten insbesondere in der jetzigen
Zeit an die BürgerInnen und Bürgerinnen
in unserem Land
zurückgezahlt werden zurückgegeben
werden
um schnell
reagieren zu können auf Veränderungen
wäre unseres Erachtens eine jährliche
Überprüfung des
einkommensteuertrisverlaufs notwendig
notwendig gewesen um die kalte
Progression auch dynamischer
auszugleichen grundsätzlich wie eingangs
gesagt begrüßen wir viele Punkte aus dem
Gesetzentwurf wir werden natürlich auch
zustimmen aber meine Damen und Herren
als Ausschussvorsitzender ist es vorhin
schon angesprochen worden lass uns mal
eins noch sagen die Art und Weise wie
die letzten oder wann die letzten
umdrucke des Ausschusses vorgelegt
wurden
lässt in dem Verfahren etwas zu wünschen
übrig das war nicht die charmanteste Art
und Weise wie man mit der Opposition
umgeht ich bitte darum dass wir in
Zukunft solche umdrücke etwas früher
erhalten nämlich auch ich weiß Frau
Kollegin Beck es ist schwierig bei drei
Parteien eine Einigung herbei zu
erzielen aber vergessen Sie nicht sind
Umgang mit dem Parlament es ist das
höchste Gremium das auch am Ende der
Tage die Gesetze beschließt nicht die
Bundesregierung und deshalb sollte man
es frühzeitig erhalten ich bedanke mich
aber trotzdem bei allen Damen und Herren
des Finanzausschusses für die gute und
konstruktive Zusammenarbeit auch unter
Zeitdruck das war nämlich auch nicht
selbstverständlich
abschließend meine Zeit ist vorbei
Inflation aus Inflationsausgleich
bedeutet auch Energiekosten
auszugleichen und das sind wir bei
weitem noch nicht am Ende 40 Cent für
kleine und mittlere Unternehmen sind
nicht ausreichend dankeschön
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den von den
Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP eingebrachten Entwurf eines
inflationsausgleichsgesetzes der
Finanzausschuss empfiehlt unter
Buchstabe a seiner Beschlussempfehlung
auf Drucksache
4.378 den Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion der
SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP auf
Drucksache
3496 in der ausschussfassung anzunehmen
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen und
die cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
die Fraktion DIE LINKE wer enthält sich
die afd-fraktion der Gesetzentwurf ist
damit in zweiter Beratung angenommen
dritte Beratung und Schlussabstimmung es
ist namentliche Abstimmung verlangt die
Abstimmung erfolgt in der westlobby
ich bitte die Abgeordneten aber noch
hier im Saal zu bleiben da noch weitere
Abstimmungen folgen werden
sie haben zur Abgabe ihrer Stimme nach
Eröffnung der Abstimmung 30 Minuten Zeit
ich bitte die schriftführerinnen und
Schriftführer ihre Plätze einzunehmen
das ist offensichtlich geschehen
ich eröffne die namentliche
Schlussabstimmung die abstimmungsorden
werden um 14 Uhr geschlossen
das bevorstehende Ende der namentlichen
Abstimmung wird Ihnen dann rechtzeitig
bekannt gegeben
wir setzen die Abstimmung zur
Beschlussempfehlung des
Finanzausschusses auf Drucksache
4.378 fort der Ausschuss empfiehlt unter
Buchstabe b seiner Beschlussempfehlung
den gleichlautenden Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung auf Drucksache
3871 für erledigt zu erklären wer stimmt
für diese Beschlussempfehlung
danke wer stimmt dagegen der enthält
sich die Beschlussempfehlung ist
einstimmig angenommen
wir kommen zur Abstimmung über den
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktionen der
cdu/csu auf Drucksache
4.382
wer stimmt für diesen
Entschließungsantrag die
cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt denn diesem
Entschließungsantrag erfordert die Union
auch den Kinderfreibetrag und das
Kindergeld entsprechend des
Existenzminimums Bericht auch an die
Inflationsrate von über sieben Prozent
anzupassen aber er wurde eben abgelehnt
zu dem Antrag der Fraktion der AFD mit
dem Titel
inflationsgetriebene kalte Progression
verlässlich stoppen der Ausschuss
empfiehlt in seiner Beschlussempfehlung
auf Drucksache
1639 den Antrag der Fraktion der AFD auf
Drucksache 698 abzulehnen wer stimmt für
diese Beschlussempfehlung
danke wer stimmt dagegen danke wer
enthält sich die Beschlussempfehlung ist
mit den Stimmen der
Koalitionsfraktionen der
cdu/csu-fraktion und der Fraktion DIE
LINKE gegen die Stimmen der afd-fraktion
angenommen so und das war also dieser
Tagesordnungspunkt